hey everybody welcome to conan o'brien
needs a friend joined by my good
companions my chums my cho's
chose yeah
yeah oh chose that's cool brownies and
chokes yeah sonam obsession matt gurley
hi gang what's up joe hey you know it's
so funny because we always chat for a
while
and um
you know take these weird mind journeys
together
and then eventually
i announce who the guest is right but i
was just looking at it right now and
thinking what if like three years from
now we're starting to phone it in
because we're not we're still giving it
at our
all so you guys are you guys still are
oh yeah we are okay well you were
phoning it in six years before we
started the podcast many times often on
an actual phone yeah
okay yeah but what if you know it's like
hey this conor brown needs a friend
james burroughs is on the show let's go
there was no
no talk beforehand you know how we could
do the fastest one possible where we say
hi and say that how about this here we
go
conor brown needs a friend
sona hi matt hi
james
burroughs i think we could do even
faster okay
cob needs friends sona matt hi james
bros
yeah i didn't say a word you said you
said i got nervous i got really nervous
but i think do you think there's a i
can't do it even better watch this okay
conor bryant needs a friend matt
james bros
and then i bring up sona later wait why
not in the intro i don't know we save
time are we gonna have beef are we gonna
break up like slash and axel one day no
they got back together again didn't they
yeah but like you know i mean what do
you think the beef will be i don't know
what do you think maybe it should be
over actual beef
i think it would be terrific
if i found out here's the beef the beef
is i find out that sona is using our new
podcast building
to store beef
that's what's up you're getting beef
through some uncle
where's this beef this is yerevan beef
the finest beef from europe that's good
beef and uh
everyone wants their beef from yerevan
you have found that in the edit room
downstairs it's cool enough to store
beef yeah and you're using it and some
of it runs and the uh the juices short
out
short out
our videos systems and various
technological
advances
we're gonna figure out like wiring like
lingo wires and
tubes and such you know what we will
never have a beef you know why because
we always have beef that's you know what
um all we do is fight yeah
this thing falls apart yes when we get
along right oh
we can never let that happen i don't
think that's a problem i think it's
going to be okay i think we're going to
be fine i think we're going to be more
than fine and i don't i think we should
just you know we're not going to vote it
in because we're always searching always
searching for new things to talk about
and it just seems to happen organically
with us we never know what we're going
to talk about and then
before you know it we've taken some
crazy cerebral journey that's explained
space-time continuum and we didn't even
know we've ever done that never did that
once
we've talked about
scrotums yeah in space porn and lots of
jizz i talk about yeah the family i grew
up with a lot yeah sort of some
dysfunctional stuff yeah yeah no it's
really nothing that contributes to
society in any way
[Music]
jim burrows
gibberish